j'ai besoin de reprendre ma vie là où
est ce qu une personne m'a ôté il ya
trois ans michel souffre depuis qu'on
lui a installé une bandelette sous
l'urètre un dispositif médical pour
traiter l'incontinence urinaire elle ne
crée pas de problème chez la grande
majorité des femmes mais d'environ 10%
des cas des complications surviennent
sur le puma soir les jambes croisées
je peux plus jouer avec mes
petits-enfants
on peut plus marcher il faut parfois
même retirer complètement la bandelette
une opération délicate et invasive
québec a déployé en mars quatre nouveaux
centres de référence pour traiter ce
problème et éventuellement retiré
complètement les bandelettes il s'agit
du centre hospitalier universitaire de
montréal de sherbrooke de québec et le
consortium et guile michel n'a pas
réussi à obtenir un rendez-vous dans
l'un de ses centres j'ai cherché sur
internet
j'ai laissé un message dans un humain
numéro chez jamais eu de retour d'appel
pourtant le ministère de la santé
confirme que les quatre centres de
référence sont en fonction en 2019
l'émission enquête avait diffusé des
témoignages de femmes opérées par des
médecins québécois qui affirmé leur
avoir complètement retiré leur
bandelettes toujours souffrante ces
femmes se sont rendues aux états unis où
un chirurgien leur enlever 10 bouts de
bandelettes encore restantes après ses
reportages le collège des médecins
recommandent à québec d'ouvrir des
centres de référence pour traiter les
femmes ici et que les médecins soient
bien formés pour faire des retraits
complet le collège demande également au
ministère de la santé de rembourser les
femmes qui se rendent aux états unis
pour faire retirer complètement leurs
bandelettes je suis allé là avec avec
beaucoup d'ouverture mais les réponses
qu'on mode donné
mon monde et sujet rêve céline s'est
récemment rendu au centre de référence
de québec où on lui a dit qu'elle ne
pourrait recevoir tous les services dont
elle a besoin pour la physiothérapie on
a aussi conseillé d'aller au privé parce
que en ce moment
dans les fans d'expertisé a pas de
physiothérapeute qui sont prêts à
soigner les femmes une information que
confirme l'association des urologues un
seul centre de services est complètement
opérationnel au québec celui du chum à
montréal
de dos et la devèze a mis en place en
avril 2002 21 évidemment avec les
pandémies comme comme annoncé c'est pas
nécessairement évident non plus c'est
pas évident il ya des retards dans les
trucs externe est de retour en salle
d'opération
l'association des urologues éclaire les
femmes qui ont besoin d'être opéré ici
le seront des urologues et des
gynécologues fondé retrait complet de
bandelettes mais en équipe parfois même
à trois chirurgiens on nous a demandé de
développer l'expertisé au québec puis
c'est ce qu'ont fait qu'on jouait avec
les jeunes écologie ses opérations en
équipe font peur en à tenir au besson
qui s'est rendu au centre de référence
de sherbrooke
il a l'impression comme d'autres femmes
que les médecins se regroupent par
manque d'expérience et d'habileté j'ai
l'impression vraiment qu'ils utilisent
comme des cobayes même constat pour
céline j'attends plus après les centres
d expertise
je vais plutôt
probablement me tourner vers un retrait
aux états unis avant l'ouverture des
centres en mars québec à rembourser les
frais médicaux 255 femme pour un montant
total de 3 millions et demi de dollars
une cinquantaine d'autres femmes
espèrent être remboursés ici nam 6 k o
et radio canada montréal